le gouvernement le goût a annoncé hier
un investissement de 60 millions de
dollars dans le secteur des bornes de
recharge électrique et pendant ce temps
le gouvernement Trudeau a annoncé que
Volkswagen a choisi 500 miles en Ontario
pour développer une usine de batterie
électrique on a plaisir ce soir de
recevoir pierrefitz Gabin le ministre de
l'économie de l'innovation de l'énergie
bonsoir Monsieur fitzgerben bonsoir
Monsieur Fillon bon il y a actuellement
parlons des bornes de recharge d'abord
et actuellement 1200 bornes de recharge
dans le réseau québécois on va en
ajouter 367 avec la noce d'hier est-ce
que ça va assez vite
on a évalué avec des experts qu'il
faudrait y avoir probablement plus de
6000 bornes on appelle des bornes de
recharge en continu c'est pas les bornes
de maisons niveau 2 il faut vraiment
6000 donc on est rendu à
1550 1600 donc je crois qu'on voit un
rythme intéressant mon collègue Benoît
charrette dans le programme de pèves
2030 d'économie verte va remettre
d'autres montants dans le futur dont il
va progressivement donc on veut
augmenter du niveau de 1000 à peu près
aujourd'hui l'amener à 6000 si 2030 vous
misez beaucoup sur l'électrification des
transports sur la filière batterie aussi
si on va plus loin là dans le
développement de ce que vous voulez
faire on apprenait hier que Volkswagen a
choisi 5 temps mais en Ontario avec un
appui quand même très important du
gouvernement fédéral on nous a pas dit
combien ça s'en vient votre première
réaction d'abord monsieur fitzguiben à
cela est-ce que c'est décevant que ce
soit pas au Québec que ça se passe
c'était décevant il y a un an parce que
faut comprendre que ce projet-là c'est
sûr que nous voulons un cellulier on
comprend que bécancourt on bâti
présentement un campus de composants de
batterie principalement Danone kata de
nickel un cellulier on en veut un je
pense qu'on va en avoir un jour
maintenant malheureusement il y a peu
près un an au printemps passé j'aurais
dit plutôt nous avons été incapables de
donner suite aux conditions de
Volkswagen qui demandaient des terrains
importants près de Montréal des années
et principalement euh la connexion
électrique que nous n'avions pas le
Volkswagen de requier à peu près 8 900
MW d'ici 7 ans on avait été c'était
impossible pour nous de le donner donc
on a dû malheureusement passer sur le
projet malgré les ambitions du Québec
malgré les milliards d'investissement
promis par Volkswagen ou un on n'a pas
courant électrique alors pour partir les
lignes on parle de Montréal non pas
court terme on va le faire depuis le
Moyen Terme long terme ça étendu il y a
d'autres terrains qu'on peut offrir
d'autres cellulier on parle à un
principalement aujourd'hui il n'a pas
d'avoir d'autres donc on a perdu
Volkswagen le 1er parce qu'on n'avait
pas les conditions qui étaient requises
mais on renonce pas on construit notre
campus bécancourt qui va très bien
d'autres annonces vont venir bientôt et
on aimerait avoir clairement un
cellulier on n'aura pas deux on va en
avoir un seul main parce que c'est très
demandant pour les besoins d'énergie
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres qui vont
passer c'est une belle occasion faut que
jewagen oui mais encore une fois si
j'avais eu si on avait eu quoi qu'on
aurait été au rendez-vous on n'avait pas
donc on peut même pas comme ça c'est
vous qui dites ça après étude ou c'est
Hydro-Québec qui vous dit on n'a pas on
n'a pas ce qu'il faut
c'est plus que ce qu'on a disponible
aujourd'hui à l'époque j'étais pas
ministre de l'Énergie seulement de
l'économie on avait regardé avec au
Québec c'est est-ce possible d'avoir le
100 m à Montréal d'ici 7 ans c'était non
techniquement c'est impossible le
ministre fédéral de l'innovation
François Philippe champagne dit qu'il y
aura des retombées pour le Centre du
Québec pour les usines de kata des
Danone est-ce que est-ce que c'est une
bonne nouvelle est-ce que c'est un prix
de consolation comment vous voyez les
choses à la base si on vient au début
c'est en 2018 quand tu es arrivé en
poste on parle même pas de batterie ça
n'existait pas je regarde ce que c'est
fait depuis 4 ans et 5 ans et
honnêtement je suis très content parce
que on bâtit on réintègre la filière
automobile avec je pense une meilleure
fondation à savoir que nous avons les
minéraux nous avons l'énergie c'est pour
à bec en cours soit produire les katas
d'A notes qui représentent en fait
pratiquement 65% de la valeur d'une
cellule donc je pense que ce qu'on bâti
présentement dans le campus de
bécancourt Trois-Rivières Shawinigan va
être une fondation des prochains deux
trois générations et effectivement les
cellules qui vont s'établir en Amérique
du Nord présentement on est le premier
qui annoncé avec Jérôme Pasco d'autres
s'en viennent la production de kata dans
votre premier donc on va on va créer je
pense un écosystème intéressant mais
c'est sûr éventuellement on aimerait
avoir un cellulier pour pouvoir au moins
offrir les cellules à nos producteurs
commerciaux ici au Québec on peut
l'avoir vraiment quand vous me dites
qu'on n'a pas l'énergie nécessaire
pour ça premièrement deuxièmement avec
Joe Biden qui investit des centaines de
milliards de dollars pour de l'achat
local pour de la production locale le
vent est fort
il y a deux choses dans votre question
la première question sur le côté
électrique je pourrais dire on travaille
les au Québec il y a des des régions du
Québec ça va être plus facile les lignes
de transmission vont être possiblement
en place plus rapidement il y a des
régions spécifiques au Québec
stratégiques on peut offrir probablement
en 5-6 ans les mégawatts de disponibles
donc c'est ça ouais mais c'est suffisant
parce que souvent on conseille une usine
de cellules prend des années donc on
manque deux trois ans Volkswagen les
maquettes de 3 ans l'autre travail plus
le temps avance plus on est capable de
faire les ouvrages alors moi je pense
qu'on va être capable d'ici un an et
demi d'avoir un cellulier le programme
durant absolument raison c'est un vent
de faire c'est important soit qu'on est
très près du gouvernement fédéral mais
ça des finances ministère de l'Économie
et on a dit on a décidé de faire des
programmes je dirais Haddock l'Ontario
fait un programme pour Volkswagen on a
un projet majeur sur lequel on travaille
où on a aussi des incitatifs qui seront
pas nécessairement égaux à ceux du
Arabie mais il faut quand même accepter
ou comprendre que l'avantage Québec
n'est pas seulement
ainsi de suite stratégique parce qu'on
peut offrir des minéraux critiques on
peut on a la zone innovation qu'on va
créer donc quand on parle de de projets
majeurs le Québec beaucoup appris
dont vous parlez c'est une flèche c'est
vraiment cette grande loi de presque
1000 milliards de dollars canadiens qui
étaient adopté par les Américains le
budget fédéral s'en vient le 28 mars
est-ce que le Canada doit avoir une loi
aussi comme ça
c'est sûr qu'il va avoir beaucoup de
pression parce que
vous dites finance beaucoup les frais
d'opération aussi on parle d'énergie
renouvelable alors si tu peux ce que les
cellules les batteries c'est plus large
que ça je pense que on voit dans le
monde beaucoup de focus sur les la
sécurité énergétique la Gy renouvelable
des Américains ont les moyens c'est ceux
qui voient beaucoup de pression sur la
production par exemple d'hydrogène alors
va falloir s'ajuster
monsieur fethiben parce que dans
l'équation le gouvernement fédéral doit
avoir sa propre politique face au
gouvernement américain ça passe beaucoup
nécessairement par le fédéral vous vous
attendez quoi madame fuirlande là-dessus
on a des édition monsieur
gérardiculaire moi je dirais que
Monsieur champagne c'est sûr qu'il faut
assez de voir comment on peut donner un
peu de crédit d'impôts si possible sur
des productions d'ingénieurs mais
honnêtement à ce moment si je n'ai
aucune idée
moi je pense que le Canada et le Québec
on doit faire partie du bail America par
exemple vous n'arrête pas de dire mais
les gens aux États-Unis à qui je parle
que nous allons offrir 10 terawatts
heure d'hydroélectricité à New York donc
nous le Québec on va décarboner York
donc on devrait pas avoir le bénéfice
dans le bail America d'être reconnu
comme étant une source importante de
contribution en logements qu'on l'a vu à
les composantes de batterie par exemple
les capteurs d'Anna dans les potes
désavantagé par rapport à Harry on parle
des gros projets on nous sommes je crois
qu'il y en ajustement qui doit être
faite j'ai pas d'idée à ce moment faire
mais faut être conscient que on veut pas
des industrialiser Canada et le Québec
non plus donc on doit mettre des mesures
en place mais on s'entend que c'est des
mesures qui sont fait ioniques la part
des grands américains très intéressant
Monsieur fitzgerbin Merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir fait plaisir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI